we've done three three galleries you
remember is you just now make the table
do forward cross I actually have more
values here than I need because if I've
got four values yellow I really really
need to to make the straight line so I'm
just going to go for three somewhere in
the middle I'm gonna compare two
quantities number of years that I've
been investing or number two use I'm
have money to make me on and then I
should actually sit down so you can say
by the amount of balance now we can
actually pick whichever ones we want but
I'm going to pick the numbers zero one
and two I think they'll be most useful
to me okay now off to zero this is the
first room on the table right it's the
start of the first year no time is
actually elapsed so that's why I'm
calling in zero what's the balance in
the account yeah mm find it all right
that's where I'm at and if you recall
just looking at the simple interspace
and freaky you get the $144 features on
top that's all it's all every time so
I'm going to put in these new values
maybe
now just like we did in the review right
I want you to look at this
I don't you help me picture what is the
equation that binds these two together
years number tables and the balance of
the account
help me awake this out how do we look at
our lost time we need two piece of
information I will need the principle
what does the principle represent it's
the beginning right if you recall I
think was brand new said it's when X
that's what I'm frustrated
what is its when X is equal to zero
right
this your intercept sir this here right
this is going to be out in y equals MX
plus B that's gonna be big
don't you agree that that's where you
begin what's the other thing we want to
in a straight line y minus F and a
gradient right how do we work out
gradient from these numbers 144 it's
this thing here right and we actually
constructed the table so we know exactly
what that amount is every time you get
that so this gap here is 144 that's the
great inner mouth time yeah is that okay
okay so here's what I want you to do
wanna see a picture okay so now I'm
ready for you to good
yeah now some of you have used this
before I want you to go to that address
and before you do anything with this I
want you to do this this will help our
graph look easy to read dirty dress I'll
zoom in in a second once you've um all
gone to the address so you can see these
little bits of details here I'll go more
clearly and we're going to get because
we're going to get a computer to draw
this graph for us that you're gonna get
so would you go to the address it'll
load up like a grid line there's been
things and then there's this um this is
rich in the top right hand corner what's
you go there you'll get this and I'm
gonna zoom in now once you get beyond
the ridge I want you to change all of
the numbers so that um you can see
there's a -2 and a 30 a - thousand ten
thousand they won't be that right now I
want you to change those numbers click
on them adjust them with your keyboard
so that you have those numbers so once
you've done that it should look like
this is what I guess you'll know you've
done it because you'll see ten thousand
right up there yet you see it and you
should see ten twenty and it might just
cut off before you actually I don't
think I can see thirty does okay
okay now remember we just went to all
this effort to take this table and get
the values out of to make this into a
straight line I know em is I don't be is
so this should be y equals and I'm gonna
go em X plus B so there's enemies and
this yeah so I'll be at the top left you
can you can hit in there and you can
actually just type through it I don't
know but you cannot just doing the
keyboard if you like I'm gonna go y
equals and you may want to drop this
down this actually I'm putting onto a
piece of paper all the way you have your
simple interest table this is the
equation that describes everything
happening with that simple interest so
let's write that in okay do you have a
life okay do you see it yeah I just made
okay so what do you see what do you see
this is straight line right and what it
represents is what is the balance as
time pluses as you go across years right
and you can see this is why they call it
flat line flat rate interest right it's
just going up at the same rate all the
way along so - yeah it's black
I'm gonna ask you to do one more thing
here I'm actually gonna ask you to go
back up the top you up in the left and
if you've got the on-screen keyboard
actually wants you to on the right
bottom left-hand corner where it's ABC
just hit that
it's um changed your scale she's got
this thing once you have got this open I
wish you'd go right into the middle and
you'll see here a pair of curly braces
that's actually what they call I love
their curly braces they look like that
okay once you get that come back to if
you hit one two three again you'll come
back to this original keyboard and all I
want you to put in on top of this is
inside there securely braces
X is greater than zero now once you do
that I want you to tell me number one
what it means and number two why am i
doing it what does it mean
what is X here what's our horizontal
axis have a look I have it right there
in my table and so do you which one of
these is X it's years right it's time
okay so why have I bothered to say X is
greater than zero
what's the significance of that it's
because time is like you can't say
although in the past before I put my
money into the bank account how much was
it worth that doesn't make sense so time
has a positive you so now you can see it
you're wired it starts from zero and off
it goes it grows and grows and grows so
far so good
okay here's where the real magic happens
right how would you come back to your
sheet
okay now on machine I hope you remember
what we did right the end of yesterday's
lesson is that we said you know what
this is nice it gives us the right
answers why it kind of is slow or
inefficient it's not the best way to do
things right so that's why we developed
this guy remember this right this is the
compound interest formula yeah it's so
much more efficient so yes
which is a time
so just coming back you have a compound
interest right it is describing the same
kind of thing but interest is given one
interest and you have interest right
so I wants to take this same thing and
notice here I can write a similar kind
of equation for it right I'm gonna have
a y equals but the numbers are going to
be a range differently right what's the
principal again we're salads two
thousand four hundred sir that's okay in
the front right then I've got one plus
what was the radio the break think about
it the rent is a percentage yeah so it's
six percent but I'm trying to get into
the habit of buying decimals so I'm
gonna write 0.06 okay he's the really
cool thing right if I say in here right
I actually want a specific number of
years but this graph this can tell us
all the number of years which letter is
it again which the letter signifies the
years it's X right this is the
horizontal axis so if I put an X out
there like this thing here instead of
simple interest will tell us comp
averages and will give us a future so
now that you have that in your head
let's have a look at this again we're
going to form an equation but this time
it's gonna look like this okay the first
it's easy you just go y equals you got
your 2400 out the front and you can see
there's brackets over here on the left
hand side right once you get one bracket
you don't end up with 1 ya plus 0.06 now
yes I looked at this point I need to do
this very here if you've looked at your
calculator I like your actual calculator
you'll recognize this is the button you
want right this is the power button so
once you hit that I need to put in the
number of years and then you get this
what's going on yeah yeah by the way is
one more thing I should do just like we
did before time only makes sense when
it's positive right so I'm actually
going to go back to the curly braces on
the ABC no X I'm glad you feel that way
it's greater this is what about to look
like okay do you see what's going lunch
you see you know I've done this raise
your hand if you got a similar key
picture on your screen hands up okay
that
maybe
you don't finish greater than zero
finish it off what we want is for I want
positive values of X plus you've done
your time right so use the greater than
symbol this one this one and zero and
then the line will come back okay sir
just step back for a second great we
have a pretty picture now what does it
says x squared 0 so missional okay
mathematics that's a great question
let's figure out that exam
ok so what does this mean what you're
seeing here is a picture all exponential
journey that's what this is that's what
mathematicians it's getting bigger and
bigger but it's doing that faster and
faster what is it any positive why is it
doing that that's right like the amount
of interest the interest itself is
getting bigger and bigger so this gap is
sort of widening and widening and
fostering pasta so now I want you to
wrap it up you can keep that open but
your exercise 6g 16 what you'll see is a
series of graphs just like this one well
mainly for mainly the pepper one you're
gonna see these right and now I want you
to understand I want you to have in your
mind right here is a simple interest
graph
it's just tracking you up at the same
rate all the way along okay what
compound interest is doing and as soon
as you have a look I'll just show you
okay there you go casing that one
does it look familiar right this is
exactly one except the things you guys
can generate this yourself you don't
need to just have to trust all okay I
guess that's what it looks like you can
see why